PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your Cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka.
And in this episode,
we welcome back
Jen Person to talk about more
mobile app backend service
solutions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good morning, Jen.
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud."
JEN PERSON: Thanks, Priyanka.
I'm always happy to be here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So last
time we were on this show,
you shared a mobile app backend
recipe solution using Firebase.
JEN PERSON: Yep.
And I explained
that Firebase solves
a lot of the mobile
app backend problems.
But if you need to make
some changes server side,
I hinted that you need
to add to Firebase
to make a complete solution.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So I
can't wait any longer.
Tell me what we're
cooking up today.
JEN PERSON: All right.
So here is our recipe
from the last episode.
And here's today's ingredients.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Ah, of course.
App Engine Standard Environment.
Well, App Engine
Standard Environment
is an app platform
that monitors,
updates, and scales the
hosting environment.
All you need to do is write your
mobile backend service code.
If your app uses Firebase
for automatic real-time data
synchronization, you can
extend your Firebase solution
using App Engine Standard
Environment to process user
data or orchestrate events.
For instance, in my game
"Priyanka's Kitchen,"
I use App Engine to compute
user ranks based on scores,
then write the updated
ranks to Firebase.
JEN PERSON: That's
a perfect example
of how this recipe can be used.
I recommend this recipe
for Firebase apps
that need a backend service to
modify the synchronized data
and backend services
that run periodically
to process or analyze Firebase
data, just like the ranking
system in "Priyanka's Kitchen."
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: App Engine
Standard Environment certainly
adds some seasoning to
the Firebase recipe.
But of course, no
one recipe will
suit every discerning palate.
So tell me, Jen, when
would you not recommend
using this recipe?
JEN PERSON: I
don't recommend you
use today's recipe for
backend services that
call native binaries,
write to the file system,
or make other system calls.
I also don't
recommend this if you
require persistent connections
to Firebase, because App Engine
Standard Environment reclaims
socket connections after just
two minutes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
But I'm betting
that you have a design that
can work for those use cases,
too, right?
JEN PERSON: Yep.
And I have it right here.
But you'll have to wait
till the next episode
to find out what it is!
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Oh, I am on
the edge of my seat here, Jen.
Thanks again for coming on.
And it's always a pleasure to
spend time on Cloud kitchen
with you.
JEN PERSON: Any time.
I can't wait to come
back to your kitchen.
I just love the smell
of freshly cooked cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
that's all for today
on "Get Cooking in Cloud."
If you would like to know
more about today's recipe,
you can check out the resources
in the description below.
Here's hoping you're whipping
up your own mobile app backend
strategy.
Join us next time when Jen
will finally reveal the mystery
mobile app backend solution.
JEN PERSON: If you
liked this video,
then check out the other
episodes in the series.
And don't forget to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
so you can be notified
about new episodes of "Get
Cooking in Cloud," as well
as other great Google Cloud
content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]